4 days ago, Claude came out and said,
"Hey, you're no longer allowed to use
your subscription inside of third-party
harnesses like Open Claw." And people
were upset because now they're paying a
lot more for AI unless they're using
something local. And then yesterday,
Anthropic says, "Hey, we literally have
a model that's too dangerous to release.
It's crushing Opus 4.6." So then today,
they come out with this thing called
managed agents with the headline of
getting to production 10 times faster.
And honestly, I've spent the past 3
hours playing around with them, and I'm
a little bit disappointed. Because after
they announced this and after they
announced this, you think, "Okay,
they're really coming for Open Claw this
time." This is basically just them
saying, "Hey, we're now allowing you to
host an agent on our cloud and our own
infrastructure, so you don't have to
spend all that time actually setting all
that up." Shipping a production agent
used to mean months of infrastructure
work first, but now managed agents
handle that for you where you basically
just define your agent's tasks, tools,
and guardrails, and then they set up
that sort of cloud sandbox environment
for all of that to be ran in. And that's
why they're basically saying build and
deploy agents 10 times faster. Now, they
are actually doing some really cool
things for certain businesses. We can
see that Notion has a managed agent
setup where teams can delegate work to
Claude directly inside of Notion itself.
They basically drag over some tasks to a
different status, and then Claude agent
picks it up and processes them. And if
you come to the docs, you can see a lot
of other actual proof of what teams are
building with managed agents. So in
today's video, I'm going to do a quick
breakdown on how they actually work,
what they cost, when you should use
them, and just kind of my honest
thoughts and why it's a little bit
disappointing to me. So if you head into
the Claude console, you can see on this
left-hand side that we have something
called managed agents over here. And if
I just click on quick start, we can
basically see a little interface where
we have some templates to choose from,
or we have a chat-looking interface
where we can just describe the type of
agent that we want and it'll just build
it. Now, the good news is you don't
actually need a subscription. So those
of you that might not have a Claude code
subscription, all you have to do is come
in here and just set up an API key,
which you do have to put in like five
bucks to get started. So let's say I
want to create an agent that's able to
analyze competitors, and it will
basically do research and then give me
an analysis on what we can do
differently as a business in order to
stay ahead of the curve. So, what
happens is it automatically over here on
this right-hand side writes out that
prompt. You can see we have a name, a
description, a model, a system prompt,
and then we have other things like an
MCP server, and some tools. We also have
the ability to give these agents skills,
which is awesome, of course. Now, I
could go ahead and create this agent or
keep refining. So, if I click on that,
it'll say like, "Hey, what else do you
want to add?" Here, what I'm doing is
asking it to change the model to Opus
4.6 instead of Sonnet 4.6, and you can
see it just changes that configuration
right there, and now I will hit create
this agent. So, what I want you to think
about as we're going through this is
your perspective. If you're someone
who's already living in Claude Code,
then this doesn't really seem that much
to you, and it's not super helpful. But,
if you are someone who is mainly living
in Claude Chat, and you've never used
Co-work or Code, then this is a huge,
huge value add for you, and you can
build agents really, really fast by just
describing a goal. And it's literally
just a five-step process. You can see we
just finished step one, which was to
create the actual agent, and now we have
to create the environment, which is a
our which is our cloud container that
Anthropic hosts, and it has
pre-installed packages. So, we're
basically just giving this agent its own
little computer in the web. So, it says
right here, "Next, we have to configure
the environment." Cool, we'll go ahead
and click on next. An environment is
like a cloud container, blah, blah,
blah. It defines networking rules, and
basically says like, "What can your
agent actually do?"
So, I have three environments set up,
but I'm just going to go ahead and say,
"Okay, let's create a new environment
for this specific agent." So, that's
what I said. It says, "What networking
access does this agent need?" I'm just
going to go ahead for the sake of the
demo and say unrestricted. And now, it's
creating that environment super quickly
for us. Once again, we're not doing
anything. All I have to do now is click
on start session. So, it says a session
is live, but before we actually test, we
need to connect to ClickUp. Now, here's
where it gets interesting. All you have
to do to connect is
it's kind of like an OAuth login,
because this uses like MCP servers and
things like that. So, once again, the
value prop here, if you've never built
an agent, and you're in Claude Code or
something, you might get lost when you
start to think about like API keys or
access.
But, here, it's as simple as signing in
and then it gets stored in your vault.
So, we have a vault that can be shared
across different people in your team. I
created one called test vault. For the
sake of the demo, let's say I want to
create a new vault in order to store
this different ClickUp credential. It
says that authorization is required to
use this MCP. I could do an access token
or I could do OAuth credentials or right
here, it just basically prompted me to
do the actual like single sign-on and
then we should be all set. I'll go ahead
and click connect as you can see and
then all I have to do is choose which
workspace I actually want to connect.
So, I choose Up and AI. It's as simple
as that. Basically, anyone could be able
to go through this flow and create an
agent and now it's already done. So, it
says that our session is live and we can
go ahead and start chatting here. But
the one thing I just realized is this
has no idea about our actual business.
So, how could it give us a good report?
So, now I'm giving it a little bit more
context about our actual business and
it's going to help us change the way
that this agent is prompted. So, if I
switch over here to the agents tab, you
can see that we have this agent. But you
have to be really careful here because
in the agents tab, we can see that I
have two versions, right? Here's the
system prompt for version one and here's
the system prompt for version two. They
didn't even change. So, I don't think
that it actually implemented that
knowledge. So, what I would do here is I
would come over and I would click guided
edit. And then I could basically say,
you need to add to the system prompt
that we run a AI coding platform
business. So, our whole goal is to help
people turn a natural language request
into software or AI agents or websites,
things like that.
This is important so that you can
actually give me a good analysis.
And now you can see it was actually able
to change the system prompts in here.
So, the agents output should be a lot
better now. So, let's go ahead and click
test run. We have to choose the actual
environment to run this thing in. So,
we're going to do competitor intel. And
now I could drop in a message like
analyze Cloud Code and it would actually
go kick off and start this session up.
Now, what we can do here is we can see
step-by-step what's going on and how
long each step is actually taking. If I
click on view session, we get a bit of a
better overview because we get like this
horizontal bar, which kind of shows us
the actual path. You can see right now
it just did four different web searches,
and it has basically all the same tools
that Claude Code does. So, when you
think of like your bashes or your reads
or your greps or your searches or your
fetches, that's basically what these
agents are doing. This is essentially
the, you know, Claude Code, you know,
the agent SDK, but it just has a nice
wrapper around it. But, it gives people
who are scared to look at something like
Claude Code a much nicer regular Claude
sort of interface. And we also have the
ability to use this ask Claude button,
which means that we could chat with
Claude to understand how this is set up
or what we're looking at or what we need
to do to make changes. So, anyways,
while that's running, let's talk about
what else we have over here. We just saw
the quick start where we could use
templates or we could just use a
conversation to start an agent.
Obviously, all of these templates are
basically just prompts with maybe some
service connected that we would have to
connect our credentials to. But, then we
have our agents. So, here you can see
that I've spun up four different ones.
I've got the competitor intelligence one
using Opus. I've got these other three
using Sonnet and a few other that I've
already deleted. But, each agent
basically has to work within an
environment. And so, that's why in this
case, I basically have one environment
for each of these agents. Now, what you
get charged on is not these
environments. You actually get charged
on the sessions being active. So, all of
these are idle, they're not costing me
anything even though the environments
are running. And what you get charged on
is 8 cents per hour that these sessions
are actually live and running, as well
as any of the actual token costs that
you're acquiring via the API. And then,
of course, down here you have your
actual credential vault where you could
share these with different people. And
within each of these vaults, you have
different connections. Like here you can
see I did the OAuth to connect to
ClickUp. If I click on add credential,
we have all of these other examples that
are already set up. And most of these
are pretty standard where you just
basically just get to sign in. You can
see that this session is now idle. So,
if we click in, we can see what
happened. You can see that this took
about 3 minutes. It used this many
tokens, and we can see kind of each
individual step that the agent took
here. So, we have our actual competitive
intelligence summary about Claude Code.
As you can see down here, it goes into
things like scale and revenue, key
strengths. But keep in mind, all of this
system prompt was created by Claude
itself. So, we would probably have to
get in there and make it a little bit
more specific. Now, what you'll notice
though is this didn't even get sent to
ClickUp, even though we actually had
this connected. So, that would be
another case where I, the user, would
have to go back and fix it there. So,
let me talk about some other things I
tried. I made one called field monitor,
which basically it looks at things that
are going on in the tech space and then
sends me a signal in my ClickUp channel.
And this is what that output looked
like. This one took me about 2 minutes
to set up. I hit run. And it's pretty
good, right? I get all this information
from the week. It gives me different
clusters of information with all of
these having sources. And it actually
was able to send that to me in my
ClickUp. And then I made another one
right here called the ClickUp research
agent, which the whole idea was that I
would basically be able to come into
this research queue area in my ClickUp.
I would be able to create a new to-do
down here for a different type of voice
AI provider. And then when I move it to
to-do, the manage agent would pick up
the task and then it would do research
and it would leave me a comments over
here. As you can see, I've got a
summary, key findings, information like
this. And then I get all the sources at
the bottom. And then it moves it to
complete. Now, the thing about this is
because our agents have to be triggered
by a call to their API, it's just not
super automatic. And it requires a lot
of glue in order to actually put the
infrastructure together. Because what I
had to do here is I had to come into the
agent and say, "Hey, go check the
ClickUp and then see if you've got any
to-dos and then fulfill them." And
sometimes that's fine. But really what I
wanted to do is I'd want it to pick up
the to-dos automatically. Which means I
would need something from ClickUp to
tell something to send an API call to my
ClickUp research agent. And I was like,
"Okay, cool. So, if I can't do that via
ClickUp webhooks, then maybe I'll just
do a scheduled automation. So, maybe
I'll just have this ClickUp research
agent wake up every 30 minutes, check
the to-dos. If there's one, it'll
process it. If there's not one, it'll
just go back to sleep and that's fine."
But it can't even do that. It can't even
wake up on a cron. And so, that's what
made me realize that this manage agent
thing, it really serves a purpose for a
specific type of person. For me,
personally, I'm probably never going to
use this because I can just do cloud
code and make things better and more
custom to my needs. Because if I wanted
this exact type of agent, which I've
actually done before when I've made a
video on it, I would just use
trigger.dev. And if you want to check
out that video, just check it out up
here. Because trigger.dev lets me just
host my code on the cloud and it can set
up crons and things like that and it can
delegate to different scripts. So, I
would just way rather use trigger.dev
than use this managed agent environment.
And it's also a lot cheaper in
trigger.dev. Cuz I mean, you're telling
me that Anthropic has a model that's so
good that it cannot be released, but
they can't just give us
scheduled crons in the cloud? Cuz at
this point, I could literally glue it
together by having a scheduled trigger
in n8n or having a ClickUp trigger in
n8n and then just making this shoot off
an HTTP request to my managed agent over
in Anthropic's cloud. But that's just
like over-engineering. Why can't we just
have a ClickUp trigger natively there or
a scheduled trigger natively there? I
just
Now, there are some other things that
are coming, which I do think are going
to make this a little bit cooler. There
are three features that were teased, but
all of these are not available yet. You
have to basically go apply for early
access. So, there are going to be
outcomes, which is defining specific
success criteria for a task, and the
agent will self-evaluate its work and
iterate until it meets the criteria. So,
it's kind of like using Karpathy's auto
research, but built into the build
phase. And I do think that that's pretty
cool. There's also going to be
multi-agent orchestration where one
agent can invoke other agents via a
callable agents tool, and a coordinator
agent delegates subtasks to specialized
agents. And this is the multi-agent
swarm pattern that is managed by
Anthropic's infrastructure. And then
what else I do think will be very cool
is persistent memory. So, memory that
survives across sessions. Basically,
meaning if I go to my sessions, let's
say that, you know, we have these two
that were ran by the competitor
intelligence agent. Each time the
competitor intelligence agent wakes up
again, it is completely stateless. All
it looks at is its system prompt. But
what they're going to do is basically
say, "This agent will have memory across
all of the sessions that it's running."
And that is going to be pretty cool.
Now, I do think there's a way that you
could Frankenstein that as is if you
just give it the right things to look at
and you have it write logs of what it's
doing, but having that be a native
feature will be pretty nice. But don't
worry, I have already applied to this. I
applied to this as soon as I saw the
form multiple hours ago. So, if I do get
access, I will definitely be making a
video about how it all works. Now, the
other thing that's interesting and worth
talking about is the CLI because the CLI
lets you build and use your managed
agents right from Cloud Code. So, maybe
there's also some value there because in
some cases what you could do is not only
build a managed agent in Cloud Code in a
project that already has like a ton of
information about you, um but you could
also then build front-ends for it
because it already understands the
configuration and what it needs. And it
also means if you wanted to delegate
some stuff to sub-agents, you could do
that from Cloud Code and not store them
here. You know, sometimes if you have
like a dot cloud and you have agents
folder, that's going to eat up some
context and maybe they don't get invoked
in the right way.
But if you have each agent pointed at a
specific API endpoints that you could
then call from Cloud Code, maybe there
is some value there. But anyways, what I
did in this project is I basically set
up a managed agent in managed agents.
So, let's say I wanted to build this
automation, right? And I'm in Cloud
Code, so I just shoot this off. And I'm
telling it to use Anthropic's CLI to
build myself a managed agent.
The goal of this would be I can drop in
a YouTube video transcript and then I
can just have it do things for me in my
ClickUp like sending me a summary as
well as potentially some action items
from that video if I found out, "Hey,
you know, I want to implement some of
these strategies into my workflow or
whatever." That's cool because I could
drop in the transcript here, it could
send off that API call to my managed
agent in Anthropic's cloud, and then
over there it would take care of all of
that ClickUp stuff. And I could just
keep coding in Cloud Code right here.
And like I said, it can also use all the
context. So, let's say I've got a ton of
information right now about my business,
about my quarterly goals, about our
current projects, it would be able to
basically use that in the system prompt
while creating this managed agent so
that the actual managed agent is a lot
more specific and tailored towards us.
So, that's where I see a lot of this
value with the CLI. Now, one thing you
do have to be very careful about if
you're building in Claude code is the
credentials because it might try to
default and send over, potentially in
the system prompt, the API keys for the
certain endpoints that you need. Rather
than if you're building it inside of
this environment over here, it's
basically going to default to using MCP
servers. So, just keep that in mind and
be careful when you're doing stuff like
that because other people might be able
to see those keys. And of course, if
it's being hosted by Anthropic and in
the conversation history, then it's
there, too. But really, if you're
curious, what I would do, and basically
the way that I teach myself everything,
is I created a Claude code project for
it. It created me this master guide on
what Claude managed agents are, how they
work, and I just had it do research on
its own so that it could explain things
to me and help me figure out how to use
it. And then just say, "Hey, you know,
like I've also been using trigger.dev,
I've also been using, you know, the
desktop scheduled automations in Claude
code. What's actually the best tech
stack for me based on me wanting to
achieve XYZ outcome?" Because it's
always not a matter of which tool is the
best, it's which tool is the best for
this specific use case. And I think that
that's just the healthiest mindset to
have around building automations and
agents. And now you can see, we just had
this agent created in our managed agent
dashboard, which is the YouTube
transcript analyzer. And I can click in
here and I can see the actual system
prompt that was created, which you'll
notice is much more robust than the ones
that
the quickstart version had us build. So,
a couple things before we wrap up here.
When you're comparing this managed agent
to the agent SDK plus trigger.dev or
something like Open Claw, that's where
you'll notice there's so many
differences. And I'm not going to read
this whole thing, but if you want to
pause it and give it a look, feel free.
But like I said, there's really two
things about Open Claw that I love and
the reason why I still use it
personally, and that is the heartbeats
and that's the ability to talk to it
from Telegram so easy. And I think that
that's what Anthropic really needs to be
doing with Claude code that would just
make it an absolute powerhouse.
Heartbeats just basically means cron,
every 30 minutes, every 5 minutes, you
can have open claw just wake up and do
things. And that's basically why it
feels like it's an always-on assistant,
besides the fact that every time you
shoot it a message, it automatically
wakes up as well. Now, of course, you
can do scheduled tasks in the desktop
app of Cloud Code, which I do, and I
have tons of them up and running, and
I've got more on my other account as
well, but it's just not the same as
being able to do a heartbeat check every
single 5 minutes to just check in on
something. And that's what I said
earlier, at this point, I'd rather use
Cloud Code to build me something with
the Agent SDK, which is very similar,
and then I would just say, "Hey,
sugar.dev, run this every 5 minutes."
So, the who should use what, if you're
just getting started with AI agents,
this is where you might want to try out
managed agents, so much easier, no
infrastructure to worry about,
hardly any API keys to worry about. But,
if you've already been building, then
there might not be as much value as you
might think. But, anyways, this whole
document that we've been looking at
here, it it does some pretty in-depth
research and comparisons about the
actual value of managed agents, and I
will put that in my free school
community for completely free. The link
for this will be down in the
description. All you'll have to do is
find the post associated with this
video, and there will be the full PDF
right in there. But, anyways, I hope you
guys enjoyed the video. If you learned
something new, then please give it a
like. It helps me out a ton. And as
always, I appreciate you guys making it
to the end of the video, and I'll see
you in the next one.
Thanks, everyone.